this one's going to be hard to fit into
a minute but i'm going to try do you
think you can be close friends with
someone that shares a different
political compass than you and do you
have strong preconceived biases when
finding out uh someone sides a certain
way politically
so i'll deal with the second one first
yes i will absolutely have biases
finding out that someone leans more
conservative on me it's going to depend
more on what specific issues and how
far conservative away from me they lean
it is going to
kind of influence things but yes there
is going to be some bias there can i be
friends with them honestly
it kind of depends it depends on certain
specific issues the big ones for me
right now
are their opinions on the state of
racism
sexism and the big one for me lgbtq plus
rights
because if someone's political position
is that i
am not valid and that my identity is
invalid and i deserve fewer rights and
don't deserve recognition no
i i can't be friends with that person i
can't work with that i can disagree on
other stuff but like i can't
disagree with that and be friends with
you